[Music]  now that Disney owns the Star Wars  franchise they're going to be cutting  some of the more obscure Star Wars  characters in television spin-offs that  have been added over the years a lot of  people think the Star Wars franchise has  been spread too thin too long so  Disney's going to eliminate less popular  characters that's right they're getting  rid of them characters like Darth  Vader's dog bark Vader is going yeah  they're getting rid of the rarely-seen  underbite Chewbacca  I love that yeah they yanked a sitcom  about a couple forced to live with their  in-laws all inside the belly of a frozen  tauntaun yeah yeah  and finally they cut back the darth  sidious storyline on two Broke Girls it  just wasn't going anywhere  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]